[Music]
hey
everybody yep we're back deep blue sea
saw a shark thing
the other day and i'm gonna call it a
flick it was a [ __ ] flick
it was definitely a flick it was cheap
though yeah
got it off the xbox one what was it 4.99
4.99
and uh first of all let me see uh hello
with everybody everybody's in the chat
room to see who's here yeah
sorry we didn't live stream yesterday
but i was like so [ __ ] tired and then
by the time like 3 p.m rolled around i
was like
yeah i was like sitting at my desk
falling asleep
and we had we didn't watch a movie
anyway so it's in there
trevor's in there man goes in there
everybody yeah everybody's here a lot of
main players
lou hernandez is here hey louie i'm
making carnitas right now just coming
back in from the kitchen i got a damn
pork butt and i covered that in
salt in um
oregano and garlic all right
no no not garlic uh salt oregano and
cumin
and then i put that down in a slow crock
pot and then i poured
um onions and garlic on it and orange
juice
about a cup and a half of orange juice
i'm gonna crock pot that down for six
hours
and then once i pull that pork i'm gonna
brown it
in a cast iron skillet give it that
crispy edges you know on the soft and
crispy that's what i'm trying to get
does that sound like a good recipe to
you i don't know but the orange juice
trick
i don't know if you've ever heard of it
anyway i've heard of that yeah i've
heard i've also heard of like putting
coca-cola in there
coca-cola which i think is the same
principle probably same idea
yeah but um that's going to be six hours
for that
six hours well we'll eat something else
you know it's the whole [ __ ]
pork bun i ate a piece of cold pizza
like a few hours ago that's all i needed
[Laughter]
but yeah so basically we were looking
for a new movie last night and i was
like well i had a couple like lined up
if we couldn't find anything
i was like really really tired and i was
like i don't really want to watch
anything that
requires too much concentration yeah or
attention
from the shark field so we're like let's
just watch this dumb shark movie
because it's like probably you won't
really have to pay attention because
it's like you know you're just waiting
for sharks to eat people basically
i got confirmation from louie that uh
yeah that orange juice is the key
yeah yeah we're going to see how that
goes i think it sounds good to me i
haven't done it that way
yeah this is the first time yeah it
sounded authentic so yeah
we'll see we'll see but yeah so um i
will say that i
saw the first deep blue sea which i
think came out way the hell back in 1999
renee harlan directed it
um i don't remember a great deal about
it but i remembered it being pretty good
i didn't see the second one i didn't
even know there was a second one because
i guess it went like direct to dvd or
something like that and that didn't come
out to like 2018
so the fact that like there was a third
one i was like wait there was a second
one um okay fair enough
let's watch uh sharks eat some people
yeah i hadn't even seen the first one
so apparently i don't know now the
original deep blue sea
did that have anything to do with like
the sharks being genetically modified or
was that a plot point that was
introduced in part two because i'm not
really sure i know somebody in the
comments earlier mentioned that they'd
seen all three of them
so i don't know i don't remember if the
sharks were genetically modified in the
first one
but i guess in the second one they were
and this is like a continuation of that
the like bull sharks that are like super
intelligent and genetically modified
so i can't i can't answer it i didn't
see the first or the second one you know
we just jumped right into i just jumped
right into this one i'm gonna say the
strength of this movie we were sleepy we
would watch this yeah
and the strength of this movie is that
you could enjoy it and kind of doze off
and then
snap back out and you really didn't miss
wait did somebody get eaten should we
back yeah yeah you didn't really
miss much i mean you could follow it or
you didn't care to follow it you just
enjoy it
by watching it it's this movie's a mixed
bag
from from you know everything that i saw
i could just tell you the production
values were
pretty good probably for the limited
budget that it was on yeah it was kind
of like a sci-fi original but
but a higher quality yeah like a real
high quality sci-fi
yeah that's kind of the vibe it gave you
know sure it's a lot better than say
like an asylum flick
but kind of that same spirit it's kind
of like you're gonna watch a [ __ ]
flick
yeah uh but the production values were
better it had
uh it had a good score um i did like the
score it kind of stood out yeah
strangely the underwater uh film
filmography
like uh cinematography was nice as well
yeah the acting was okay it was you know
it was oh no no come here poop no
[Laughter]
it depended on what it is like who's
talking about fish up here
acting was okay uh the actors were
um what i liked about this is that the
actors were all uh
physically fit so if a dude was whip
whipping somebody's ass
it looked like he could whip somebody
although i have to say there's one scene
near the end of this please stop it what
are you doing boop
i said no you've been banned you've been
banned
if she would now like we moved the
laptop back so she can't go behind it
anymore she's like oh [ __ ] i'm just
gonna step on it yeah it's different now
but i will say like um in in line with
that one scene that i thought was very
very funny toward the end because like
the ship that comes i mean the
the ship that comes like all the dudes
on are like ridiculously buff right
yeah and there's one scene later on
where i was just kind of like
yeah were these like two guys are just
like
like beating the crap out of each other
like and this is near the end when the
shit's already hit the fan and the
sharks are running around and everything
yeah
so i was just sitting sitting there
thinking the other characters must be
thinking you know will you write it up
children please stop beating each
other's asses for two seconds so we can
deal with the shark problem please
it was just like very very funny to me
well they're they're they're catering to
the audience
this is supposed to be an action flick
yeah so you got to have guys that look
like they're ready for action
they're not [ __ ] related to the gills
you know what i mean they're
you know it's not like it was back in
the 80s where it was just [ __ ]
ridiculously big
or everyone looked like a cartoon guy
yeah you have to understand the
evolution of bodybuilding and what the
[ __ ] golden era was you know back in
the 70s in arnold and [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] right you know [ __ ]
uh
what was happening on the beaches of
california yeah the dudes [ __ ] got
ridiculously big you could get anavar
and d-ball really easily you know and if
you [ __ ] had the right friends you
[ __ ] go to the gym you'd have a good
time
you see to the average person going to
the gym is like something you don't want
to do to those [ __ ] muscle heads back
in the golden era that was like their
social event was like going to the bar
they stayed there all [ __ ] day they
went when they didn't have to work out
they just watch other guys work out and
help other guys work
that was their seat so yeah those dudes
[ __ ] got ridiculously big well these
dudes are not that big
um mancus is the ship called the jason
momoa holy [ __ ] that would have been so
funny if they did that
i can't remember what the ship was
called but it wasn't that unfortunately
yeah
but it was uh you know
it was better than an asylum flick you
know what i mean but yes but you could
say you could say a similar
spirit to it and i'm not talking i'm not
talking [ __ ] about asylum
asylum had some [ __ ] badass flicks
that i like i love nazis to the center
of the earth that's a masterpiece well i
mean
they're they don't make any like they're
not trying to be something that they're
not they're like look we make
cheap cash grab knockoffs of like
popular movies
and they're [ __ ] yeah and we make
money doing it and they're gonna be over
the [ __ ] top
and if you're a kid you love it if
you're an adult you'll laugh at it and
you'll still have a good time that was
that's the [ __ ] concept and it does
kind of work
yeah the the worst thing you could do
with a low budget flick
action flick is that to make it boring
if it's boring you [ __ ] failed
it's got to be just look at velocipaster
they're
an inch of boring in that movie cheap as
[ __ ] funny though man [ __ ]
master edit you know [ __ ] edit is
just the [ __ ] you know
and i wouldn't put it in the same
category as
velocipaster i mean it's not that good a
velocity
if you ask me it's better because it's a
total [ __ ] show
you've gone to see that movie because
it's a [ __ ] show
and it delivers on all shitty [ __ ]
just
360 degree [ __ ] 24 7
on roids and you [ __ ] love it with
kung fu flicks in it and everything
this isn't like that this is supposed to
be a little bit more serious
yeah but it is still in a way though i
think this movie could have done i mean
i know the original deep blue sea was
kind of serious and i'm assuming the
second was kind of serious
it does have a serious story behind it
that's the problem with it i think
i think yeah i think that could have
done um better if it had gone a little
bit like not
wacky necessarily but like but more fun
more over the top
this one it's entertaining but i feel
like it got bogged down a little bit too
much with like
character drama and stuff like that i'm
like i don't care about these people i
just want
the sharks to snack on them so it's like
really the only characters that i
actually liked
were like the one couple that still
lived on this island because like the
the story behind this is that
there's this woman uh who
her name's emma i guess and she's like
uh she's living on this little bitty
island
called little happy and it's basically
it's
it's barely even an island it's just
this tiny little speck of land that
still has a few villages on it because i
guess like you know because sea levels
have been rising so it's been like
it's been like sinking down so pretty
much everyone has left
except for this one couple and this like
research team
that's there um researching like the
great whites that live around there
and so then you know the genetically
modified bull sharks i guess from the
second one
they uh apparently come to feed at this
place and start feeding on the great
whites because so you can tell bad as
they are
and then like a ship full of all the you
know muscle head dudes
uh follows behind them and saying
they're looking for them and of course
they're bad guys and they have like
nefarious
purpose and also there's character drama
between
two of the people on the research team
are you know
having a little meet cute and being in
love and everything and then
one of the evil dudes that comes on the
ship
is also emma's ex-boyfriend i guess yeah
so there's some character drama there
but like i said i feel like they didn't
really need any of that no
i feel like i was just like can people
just start falling in the water and
letting sharks bite them in half
because that's that's i mean let's be
honest that's what everybody wants
and you do get to see that you do get to
see people's heads and arms bit off you
can see people bit in half and it's
awesome
but i just kind of wish they would have
done more it would have gone it's like
you said i'm gonna agree with you it
should have been it should have taken a
tone but then again
it probably would have been outside the
scope of the original series and maybe
this one has a fan base
maybe it does well i guess it does
because they made two
vehicles they made two cells so who am i
so
somebody must people personally
watch it me personally the ultimate
shark
flick all right [ __ ] show flick was the
meg
yeah the meg was [ __ ] i loved that
movie it felt like
an old 80s [ __ ] movies or an early
90s movie
kind of like jurassic park or something
had that well that was but that had a
lot more comedy a lot more
fun you know this one had like a few
like comic like throwaway lines but
really like only one of them made me
laugh i think and i don't even remember
what it is right
[Laughter]
in terms of like serious serious or
serious
ish shark flicks was that one that had
um stallone's daughter in it what was
the name of that when they went down to
that damn cenote and they had the
[ __ ] shots
what the [ __ ] was the name of that some
of you guys might deep hole or deep hole
actually that's the [ __ ] bad ass
[ __ ] shark that's the porn pair
deep hole didn't you i thought you said
something last night about some movie
you were watching and you said something
and i was like oh that's the porn parody
version i said it's talking about the
starship
intercourse oh that's right yeah that's
not good because we were watching old
star trek after and i was like
my ship would be called the intercourse
like i don't mean it like that you've
got a dirty mind i don't know the [ __ ]
i don't know where i come up with this
stupid [ __ ] that would be well like i
said i would be very sad if there wasn't
a
star trek porn parody that wasn't
47 meters down yes 47 meters that was
the name that's right
that's when they were in the cenote yeah
no no no no no no no
no wait was it 47 we saw that when that
was the girls trapped in a cage
47 yeah but there was a sequel
yeah i think we saw this yeah maybe it
was i think it was the sequel
yeah the first one was like the girl
trapped in the cage and like the sharks
were just like incidental like that was
just like another
yeah you know danger that they were
facing yeah they were in some kind of
cenote look at
looking at mine and stuff if i remember
correctly weren't they yeah then there
was like a big-ass shark
coming i guess they were in fresh water
and somehow the sharks got in the fresh
water yeah i think that was the sequel
to 47 years down
yeah it was all right it had stallone's
daughter in it
what's her name [ __ ] like i don't know
she was she's kind of cute she's cute i
forgot her name
it's like you come up with all these
questions you asked it's like i don't
know you know you got the [ __ ] good
memory
i'm not google i don't think you know
what i mean i can't she's got a good
memory for names my name is yeah but i
can't remember everything just like
right off the bat like that
it might be like celeste stallone or
something like that i don't know i don't
know that doesn't sound right
like if you said it i'd probably
remember it but yeah 47 meters down
uncaged that was the name of it
yeah but yeah so it's kind of the same
thing with this one like
um you know the shark effects were good
it seemed like they used a lot of real
sharks like at the beginning obviously
the
bull sharks were uh cgi but the cgi
actually wasn't too bad
yeah it was hit and miss sometimes it
looked great sometimes it didn't quite
look that good the motion was not
it was spotty yeah but you know what
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it
yeah you know what you're watching you
know what i mean i did like that
the the effect of that one guy but
getting bit in half yeah
i thought although i have to say though
that i thought that editing now
keep in mind that i did doze off for a
couple minutes like
it was because i was like really really
tired it's not so much that it was
boring or anything but it's like
and you fell asleep for like a
significant period of time yeah i was in
and out of it because
because i heard just knowing but so you
were sleeping like through some of that
i slept through about 40 minutes of it i
don't think it was 40 minutes but it was
30.
yeah maybe half an hour maybe 20 minutes
but it didn't matter the first part of
the there was too much story and
that's what i mean the first part of it
was right because i'm sitting there
going
when's people going to get even by
sharks and kind of like
the gimmick of this one is that they're
on a man-made floating island that once
had 800 people on it
yeah well it used to be an island with a
village on it but because
but now it's so now it's just kind of
like this little rickety thing with like
a few
falling down villages and what was
happening and [ __ ] what had me [ __ ]
rolling was like the first 15 minutes of
the movie
was like a documentary on global warming
well she because she was a scientist and
she was making it like for them
because that's how they were
establishing like why this island looked
the way it did
and why she was studying the sharks but
it was kind of funny
you could have in in a in a better edit
that would have been edited down just to
a few [ __ ] offhanded comments
you know what i mean it sounded like a
commercial they probably got paid to say
that i don't know
but it was just a little bit tedious and
i was just like man look at this
and the fact that she's a teacher and
she's a teacher so she's telling it to
you
like a teacher and you're like i'm back
in school i'm watching a documentary
i mean they could have put that
exposition in there but i don't know if
i would have put it like
it's too much of it well i don't know if
i would have put it like the first thing
in the movie yeah
because you're already like going oh
okay we're going we're going to [ __ ]
get a lesson
you know what i mean and that started
getting kind of sleepy and
she's a good-looking actress and she's
swimming around in those swim trunks
[ __ ]
with the [ __ ] wedgie and the camera's
[ __ ] zooming in and up on it
but i still [ __ ] fell asleep
[Laughter]
she was in texas chainsaw massacre in 3d
yeah she was
i think she was on lost as well she
looked real familiar
yeah she's been in other [ __ ] so it's
kind of cute she's cute i guess
yeah you know how old she's probably
about 40. i have no idea
i think she's in her late 30s but yeah
she's in good shape
like i said it's it's just so much that
this is exactly like the kind of movie
that you think it's going to be
yeah you know what it is what i thought
it was yeah it's like it wasn't any
it's like it wasn't like awful and it
wasn't great it was just like oh okay
here's like a shark
like i said i could have done with more
gore i could have done more shark
attacks also i was going to say too
there was one shark attack particularly
near the end
where i thought the editing was like
kind of because basically it had to do
in this
you know spoiler alert in case you care
but um
it had to do with like one of the sharks
like jumping out the water and like
take did he take someone's head off or i
see the thing
well they were at the editing was so
weird that it's like i couldn't really
tell what happened
i was just like suddenly there was just
like this pushy thing like flying by
and then like there's blood everywhere
and then later they're like dragging the
body and it looked like it didn't have a
head on it
so i was like oh okay that's what
happened he just like snapped it snapped
his head off like a tootsie pop
but it's like i couldn't i couldn't tell
that that's what was happening like in
the moment
you know what i'm saying cause i'm like
what just did he does he eat him it is
in his mouth what's going on
the tone the tone wasn't quite right i
mean
we rented this [ __ ] for 4.99 yeah
it's a bargain at 4.99 i guess a lot of
people probably wouldn't even see it
though it's
it's the situation is is that you're in
your house during lockdown
you've you you've whip out the [ __ ]
xbox you click over to the xbox you want
to see something you see this [ __ ]
shark move you have some beer and nachos
yeah you go okay
all right and you see that budget price
and you go okay
but you know what let's just see the
sharks and that's basically what we did
because there were like there were three
that i was like kind of
going in between and like one of them
looked really good but i was like i
don't like that one looks like a more
psychological horror thriller and i was
like i like to concentrate on those
and i was like so sleepy that i'm like i
don't know if i'm gonna be able to
concentrate on like hear everyone's
dialogue because i was so tired
yeah so it's like i just want something
that doesn't like have a lot of like
emotional investment
and in that way it kind of failed
because it was a little wordy there was
a little too much of a complicated story
there was too many scenes with acting
and stuff it would have been better had
they done yeah that's my criticism
had they dumbed it down a lot [ __ ]
put a lot of [ __ ] high energy fun
scenes in it and
had been had it totally been more like
meh the meg i actually would have paid
closer to attention to it
yeah you know um that was
that was the mistake with this movie but
one thing about this movie is it
it's a demonstration that you can make a
pretty good quality
movie for not much money and then you
can stream it
on xbox or on the internet and probably
make a profit on it over time
but i think you have to have the right
edit and you have to have the right tone
it has to be more fun it has to be
something more like turbo kid or the meg
man i really liked turbo turbo kit was
awesome
i want to turbo kit on blue on blu-ray
yeah it's got like i think it's on
shutter and it's got like i think it's
got five skull rating on there yeah
i love that [ __ ] yeah that's not a high
budget movie but that's that's a [ __ ]
fun
perfect movie well like i said if you
got a good writer if you know somebody
that knows what they're doing a good
writer and a good editor i mean
you know well the business model of
hollywood's been using is churn out a
bunch of [ __ ]
and you know churning a bunch of it out
at once they'll eat it up well you're
now
starting to [ __ ] compete with
yourself when you start doing that they
need to make less movies
per year i think they have to be better
written
more fun and lower budget and so they
have to have a high impact
you don't spend a lot of money it makes
a lot of money because everybody likes
it yeah and i mean that'll work
i feel like that's kind of the best
business model anyway because
you get too much into these like bloated
like let's we spent 350 million dollars
to make this movie
you're already like crippling yourself
like because you're like well this has
to make like twice that back
right you know and it might but it might
not
the error the era of those [ __ ]
billion dollar blockbusters [ __ ] and
those big old [ __ ] superhero movies
that's gone because the thing is even if
you make a movie
even if you don't spend a lot of money
on a movie and it doesn't make that back
it's like you're only out
what are you out like a million bucks or
something like that you're not out 350
miles good example would be good joker i
don't think joker cost very much
to make that [ __ ] made a million bucks
why
badass writing because it was a good
movie badass writing and good [ __ ]
quality acting
so it made a billion dollars yeah that's
that's the way they have to like i said
you don't have to have like alts and i'm
not like [ __ ] on i'm not [ __ ] on
like special effects or anything like
that because that can be used to good
effect too but just like anything
it's all in service to a good story you
want a good story that people are
that are people are gonna get involved
with i'm gonna go ahead and [ __ ] on
special effects
i'm gonna go ahead and [ __ ] on them you
ready i'm gonna [ __ ] on i don't know if
i'm ready i'm gonna explain
it should i should i brace myself or
okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna [ __ ] on them because
the younger generations even me we grew
up with special effects
i'm now to the point where i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm almost immune to the imagery
like i don't care what i see it's really
the story
well like i said and the fun the special
effects should be in service observatory
it shouldn't be the story right and
those marvel movies it was the other way
around
i'd watch it but it'd be kind of like
riding on a roller coaster or a ride at
disneyland and when the movie was over i
couldn't even tell you what happened
i didn't remember what happened then i'm
in the car remember that
when you're in the car driving back home
and i was like yeah that was a pretty
good movie i had fun
what happened in that you know what i
mean what actually happened
and there was a lot of visuals in it but
not much spiritually you know what i
mean there wasn't much it didn't they
didn't change your
opinions on the world you didn't really
learn anything it was just
empty kind of soulless and real
corporate
that's the way it felt yeah it's like
like disney
yeah and we live right near disney world
you go to disneyland
it's just empty and corporate and
sterile really
generic as [ __ ] yeah and low budget and
that's just kind of where they fail
i will say that i'm interested as to why
deep blue sea in particular why somebody
felt the need to make
a third one i mean like and that's like
that's not really i'm not insulting it
or anything really but i'm just saying i
think it was interesting
that they chose to make a third one in
the series even though
i mean the market particularly the low
budget market is pretty
um it is a glut of shark movies
and i can see why that is because sharks
are [ __ ] scary right but it's like
i mean what we did ouija shark
and i've even look if you look on to be
like at all the like really
you know really super cheap like horror
movies there's like a [ __ ] ton of like
shark movies
i guess because of sharknado like some
people are trying to recapture some of
that magic
maybe i don't know it's just kind of
like
and i mean the whole reason that those
people made ouija shark was because you
know there are so many shark movies and
there are so many ouija board movies
that they're like why don't we combine
them and it wasn't entirely successful
but i could see why
they were like well if everybody's
seeing shark movies and everybody's
seeing ouija board movies maybe if we
make one that combines them it'll be
like a reese's peanut butter cup you
know what i mean it'll be like two great
things to go great
yeah i kind of feel like i got louis
hernandez in there who keeps track of
all my quotes is quoting me
and it says the key to a good flick is
mediocre
that sounds exactly like some [ __ ] i'd
say yeah it does yeah
well the acting can't be between a flick
and a film and cinema
okay [ __ ] flick flicks you kind of
want
mediocre acting sometimes depending on
the edit and the tone of the movie
well if depending on the tone of the
movie it's like if you're gonna do
like for example we keep bringing this
up if you're gonna do velocipaster
yeah you want you want the acting that's
like over the top bad
but like on purpose yeah if you're doing
a movie like this like an asylum movie
that's just kind of like a rip off of
you know like uh atlantic rim or
something which was like a rip off of a
pacific rim
you want acting that's just kind of like
not
so bad that it's going to stick out but
not so good that it's going to stick out
you want it kind of like
in the middle when it comes to something
like velocipaster
all right the the mediocre acting isn't
really on the actors it's on the
director
because you don't want to get a great
actor and tell him to pretend that he's
a mediocre actor
you as a director want to hire a
mediocre actor
and go he's perfect for this [ __ ]
film that's what they're doing
that way he goes i know this dude's
gonna [ __ ] it up i'm gonna make you
yeah you're gonna be the lead i know
this dude's gonna yeah so that's on the
directors the director selecting
the best quote air quotes best actors
for the [ __ ] roles you know what i
mean like
be like you know the love interest in a
b movie is a girl who can't act she's
got a [ __ ] killer bot
and shit's bouncing that's you know what
i mean and he's gonna select one that
can't act because that's what fits the
movie
yeah you know back in the days they did
it just because they had no choice
but when you're making something like
velocipaster you're doing it on purpose
yeah you know now the girl she thinks
she can act you know
but the director knows she can't act
well it's always kind of better it's
just kind of like and i think i've
discussed this before but it's just kind
of like the movies that worked out the
best don't say like mystery science
theater
were movies where the person making the
movie thought they were making a good
movie and failed spectacularly
because look at how like epic [ __ ]
you know everybody talks about you know
uh tommy wiseau like the room or talks
about birdemic or something like that
because
those people thought that they were
making good movies and failed
spectacularly and that adds a whole new
layer of comedy onto it which makes it a
lot more enjoyable
i feel like it's much harder to make a
bad movie on purpose
um it can be done because like i said
i'm a velocipaster they were trying to
make a bad movie on purpose and they
succeeded
but in a lot of ways i think it's i
don't know it takes a lot of the fun out
of it i think it's much funnier if
you're trying to make a good movie and
it just like turns out really really
yeah well we're on we're on a different
movie now
okay but people seem to be enjoying the
fact that we're on a different route
when there's when you have a director
who thinks he's making a masterpiece
and it's just a piece of [ __ ] okay yeah
like like
like manos hands of fate yeah okay
it becomes great because it's kind of a
thing of ridicule
yeah all right that's what i'm saying
that's one aspect in a way
it's kind of an insult to the people
that made it you know what i mean but
[ __ ] them i mean you're the audience you
can do that
but when you're talking about something
like velocipaster the
the director knows this is a piece of
[ __ ] and he's going to lean
straight into it being a piece of [ __ ]
until it comes right around the other
side
and achieves a form of greatness yeah
all right
which i can understand that too and if
you if you're working with a small
budget and shitty actors you better do
that
yeah the script better be the script and
the edit
it just might be the [ __ ] craziest
[ __ ] you can come crazy as [ __ ] and
and you're winking at the audience the
whole time going yeah this is what we're
gonna show you
that one that one horror movie that had
was kind of like that
the one where everybody in it was a
[ __ ]
remember the two vampire girls yeah yeah
yeah what was the name of that one uh
two vampire girls and then they had the
exorcist yeah they had the girl from
[ __ ] 45
[ __ ] the italian jellyfish the nun
with the gun
that wasn't an italian oh yeah that's
right it was an american
it kind of felt like an italian movie
yeah but yeah like that's
that's a good example of that where you
just say [ __ ] it you go from shitty and
go all the way back around oh great
yeah because like i said that one with
you that one was just kind of like
hey you like vampires we're gonna have
vampires and
uh and exorcists and demons and aliens
and cannibals and like what the [ __ ]
else is in that book yeah it was pretty
good
i'm still going to say velocirapte takes
the kids like i said that's
that's like the gold standard that's the
golden gold standard because they got
that
exactly exactly right exactly exactly
right
yeah that dude's a genius i want that
[ __ ] on blu-ray
i want that i do too actually steel book
edition
steel book edition blu-ray yeah
but yeah like i said i you know it
wouldn't have fit in with the rest of
the franchise i guess like to do
deep blue c3 that way yeah but it would
have been interesting if they had like
taken at that direction
maybe not because like i said there's so
many like low-budget shark movies that
it probably would have just got lost
in the shuffle um but you know what are
you gonna do this
it's like i said if you're not we were
just tired and we were like let's just
watch the sharks i just want to get see
people get bitten in half i'm scared of
sharks so it's like
shark movies i like them because it's
like that's always scary for me
now um sophie uh dug up
that her name is sistine yeah yeah
that's cool name actually
yeah it's cool you think i would have
remembered that because that's a pretty
cool she's cutie too
good genetics of course stallone being
his [ __ ]
superior self with his ability his
hollywood ability to snag the hotties of
course he's gonna
breed out breed some [ __ ] hotties
yeah all right yeah
are you done i'm done i gotta get back
to cooking [ __ ] yeah get back get back
to your carnitas
yeah i think that i think it's upset i
think it's pretty good it's gonna watch
it
okay oh we see you gotta make something
else because we can maybe we'll see yeah
yeah we're gonna eat something else
that's gonna take too long okay yeah
cause i was like six hours i'm not
waiting that long to eat something holy
crap
well it's so much meat you know i mean
we'll eat off that for [ __ ] days
yup definitely okay but so we'll
probably be more like somebody tomorrow
yeah wait now today is wednesday right
that today was tuesday no it's wednesday
okay okay all right yeah it's wednesday
that's right so that means we probably
won't live stream tomorrow unless we do
just like make up
for not doing it yesterday i don't know
we'll think about it we'll see if we uh
watch something that we feel like
talking about and uh but then after that
if not then we'll see you guys again on
the live stream on saturday
our next uh fun
live stream episode this is going to be
another fun topic
if you're if you're on patreon i think
you should already know what it is but
i'm not going to tell anybody else it's
not because
it's a secret all right so we'll see you
guys either tomorrow or saturday
uh thanks for dropping by as always bye